we're going to begin with breaking news
from the occupied West Bank where two
Israelis have been killed in a suspected
shooting attack it happened near the
Palestinian town of kawara just south of
Nablus the two men aged 60 and 30 were
targeted while they were inside a car
wash violence in the occupied West Banks
got worse over the past year after near
nightly raids by Israeli forces and
settlers assaults on Palestinian
Villages let's bring in Nita Ibrahim
who's joining us live now from Bethlehem
what more do we know about what's been
going on Nida
we know that the Israeli Army is
treating what happened as a suspected
shooting attack that took place at a car
wash in the beginning there was a lot of
confusion about what happened exactly
it's a Saturday it's not usually a time
when many Israelis are roaming in the
occupied West Bank but some of them
actually do to go to Palestinian places
and according to the initial
investigations they're talking about a
man who approached the two swings and
shot them at a close range and then
managed to fill the scene the Israeli
Army has been raiding several towns and
Villages near the Hawaii town that have
been really a flash point of attack by
Palestinians against Israelis and by
Israelis also against Palestinians we've
seen one of the most violent attack
thickness in awara with Israeli settlers
rampaged in the village and in the town
at Burning Palestinian homes and
Palestinians will tell you that the
Israeli Army is soon to go and arrest
Palestinians and find them when there is
a shooting attack that targets Israelis
but when the settlers attacked
Palestinian homes many of them were only
subjected to house arrest and released
from prison Anita thank you very much
indeed need Abraham bringing us up to
date from Bethlehem
is a political analyst and a contributor
to harat's newspaper he's joining us now
from Tel Aviv very good to have you with
us sir on Al Jazeera why is it that the
town of hawara is such a flash point
uh the reason is that uh it is uh
located
in an area uh which uh brings together
people who really don't like each other
on one hand uh the uh settlers are
crossing the uh Road 60 on their way to
Israel to Jerusalem or to Tel Aviv and
the Palestinians are using the same role
the same route
um and it's a point of friction and uh
what happened in February
shows that uh you're traveling when the
settlers entered hawara and burned
houses and uh it was a kind of a program
in in this was in retaliation to
incident where two brothers two Israelis
were killed by Palestine
so it's it was not a matter of
if it will happen again who is going to
get killed this was the question and
when is it going to happen
um and uh I'm afraid that it's not the
last time that you're going to ask this
question
one of the things I noticed was that
apparently there had been plans for
quite some time to build a bypass around
hawada that would allow Israelis to move
to get around to the settlements
um without passing through the center
center of town passing through uh
Palestinian areas what's been the delay
with that bypass because that would seem
a logical response to the violence that
we've been seeing
yeah it's an interesting question I
think that uh part of the the answer is
that you have in the Israeli governments
people like the minister smartwidge and
bengware who want to show the world and
to the Palestinian
who is the boss who is in charge and uh
putting more money on building bypass
roads shows some kind of weakness in
their View and uh what they really want
is the Palestinians like they do in
Hebron and it's uh it is succeeding is
to get out of there and to make their
life so visible that Israel will not
need to build a bypass road the the
Palestinian will find their Road out of
the area what they call Judea and
Somalia it's a zero-sum game for them
Anita was just talking to us earlier
about the fact that there has been such
a regular number of uh attacks on both
sides that we've been seeing I want to
ask you how this is going to affect uh
in global geopolitical terms how this
what kind of effect this is going to
have I mean we're obviously talking
about the the Abraham Accords which were
initiated under the Trump Administration
to try to encourage normalization of
relations between Israel and Arab
Nations as we're seeing this cycle of
violence in areas like khawada how do
you think other regions other potential
signatories to those Accords are going
to react to all of this
yeah uh well before I answer you uh
Global question
um I I have to say that this is not a
typical incident since uh you know
settlers are not driving on Shabbat and
uh it's very weird that uh the location
was uh in a in a car washing unit
um so I'm not sure if uh we know that
this was a terrorist attack and not some
kind of a criminal action uh the the
settlers
um are very careful because most of them
are Ultra religious is uh not to uh
attack on on Shabbat and uh only if it
is self-defense or they can use the
argument of self-defense now to to your
question
um yeah I think that uh what happens in
the global area and not only in the
Middle East I think that if you look at
the uh Global picture the relationship
between Israel and the United States it
is very hard now for the United States
to push harder on the Saudis to open an
embassy in in Tel Aviv or in Jerusalem
and the second thing is uh that the
Israeli Army right now
um is uh
perceived in the our world and the
Israeli Society is very fragile and uh
actually this is not uh the time to do
business with with Israel uh like you
know this is unprecedented that the
president of the United States refuses
to see the prime minister of Israel and
that thousands of Israeli veterans
Pilots are refusing to serve in in the
Army so I don't see that uh the uh
Saudis or any other Arab neighbors would
like to shake hands with uh
um a prime minister who is considered
Pariah in the United States and in
Europe
it's really interesting to get your
thoughts on this we appreciate it sir
thank you very much indeed for your time